[موسيقى]
منذ وقت ليس ببعيد لم يعرف العالم سوى
ثلاثه عناصر غذائيه اساسيه فقط في الغذاء
البروتين والكربوهيدرات والدهون وكان سوء
النظافه هو السبب الرئيسيه للاصابه
بالامراض حتى عرف العلماء الفيتامينات
واخترعوا المكملات البديله التي شكل ثوره
في علوم الغذاء فكيف حدث ذلك
حتى بدايه القرن العشرين لم يلاحظ الكثير
من العلماء ان خلط الارز مع الحبوب يؤدي
الى تدمير فيتامينات بالحيويه ما يسبب
ظهور القروح وتلف الاعصاب وان تعقيم
الحليب يدمر محتواه من فيتامين سي ما يسبب
الاصابه بالاسقربوط لكنهم فهموا ان نقص
بعض المواد في الغذاء قد يسبب المرض وان
الطعام يحتوي على اكثر من ثلاثه عناصر
غذائيه سميت المواد الاضافيه
في عام 20912 صاغا كاس ميرفينج مصطلح
فيتامين في ورقه علميه وقدم رؤيته بان
المغذيات قد تساعد على علاج الامراض ما
ادى الى ظهور العديد من المكملات الغذائيه
البدائيه مثل فيتامينات الخميره والخميره
ذات القوه المزدوجه ومركزات الحديد
بالمقابل شهد عام 1916 تطوير اقراص
لتحويل فيتامينات سي بي واي والحديد
وقدمت على انها علاجات للحموضه المعويه
والامساك بالاضافه الى دورها في تنقيه
الجلد وزياده الطاقه واستخدمت كمقويات
للمساعده في زياده الوزن في حالات الضعف
بسبب سوء التغذيه
[موسيقى]
مع انتشار الاستخدام بدا الاطباء يعترفون
بدور الفيتامينات وايدت الجمعيه الطبيه
الامريكيه ما زعم فونت الذي قدم ايضا
عمليه الاستخراج الفيتامينات اي ودي من
زيت كبد سمك القد وتحويلها الى حبوب مغلفه
بالسكر كبديل للطعم المزعج في عام
1941 رعت الحكومه الامريكيه تقديم اول
بديل غذائي المجاني وهو منتج ارضي ايز
الذي كان سته فيتامينات ومعدنين وذلك
بعد التواصل لحقيقه
الذين تم استدعائهم للخدمه العسكريه اثناء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه كانوا يعانون من
اعاقه مرتبطه بسوء التغذيه في عام
1973 بدات شركه تدعى ميجا فود في صنع
الفيتامينات من طعام حقيقي كما شهيد عام
1984 انتشارا لمنتجات انت عاملنا
الفيتامينات المتعدده مع الانزيمات
والاحماض الامينيه والاغذيه الفائقه مثل
حبوب لقاح النحل وعشب القمح وعشب الشعير
واسبيرولينا اليوم وبعد 100 عام تغير
الفهم العلمي لهذا المنتج الثوري واصبح
لدينا العديد من الخيارات حيث لم تعد
الفيتامينات تاتي على شكل حبوب فقط بل قد
تكون سوائل ومساحيق ومضغا وعلكه
[موسيقى]